[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم توصلت ايران
والدول الكبرى يوم الثلاثاء في العاصمه
النمساويه فينا الى اتفاق بشان ملف طهران
النووي ياتي الاتفاق في خضم حاله من
التوتر وانعدام الثقه بين ايران ودول
المنطقه وذلك على خلفيه عدد من الملفات
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين الى اي حد استوعب الاتفاق الهواجس
العربيه بشان ايران وبرنامجها
النووي وما هي التاثيرات المحتمله للاتفاق
على مواقف ايران من ملفات الصراع في
[موسيقى]
المنطقه يجمع المحللون في ايران والغرب او
يكادون على ان اتفاق فينا بين الدول
الكبرى وطهران بشان الملف النووي الايراني
يمثل خطوه سيكون لها ما بعدها استنتاج
ينطلق ولا شك من الحسابات الايرانيه
والغربيه لمضمون ومترتب هذا الاتفاق الذي
سينعكس وبقوه على طرف لم يكن ممثلا في
طاوله المفاوضات انهم العرب وخاصه في دول
الجوار الايراني الذين طالما شكوا مما
تغول ايران في المنطقه حتى وهي مثقله
بالعقوبات التقرير للزميل فتحي
اسماعيل بين اصوات التطمين وصيحات التخويف
التي تجتاح العالم من الاتفاق بين ايران
والغرب ترقب المنطقه العربيه وتترقب
تاثيرات هذا الاتفاق على اقليم يبدو مثقلا
بتدخلات طهران المتنوعه فهل سيكون الاتفاق
قيدا يضبط السلوك الايراني ويملي مزيدا من
المسؤوليه ام سيكون تفويضا دوليا
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه لمزيد الامساك بشؤون
المنطقه لا سما جيرانها العرب ذلك مرهون
بتحديد ما هو الاستراتيجي وما هو التكتيكي
في السياسه الايرانيه عربيا ستمثل اليمن
وسوريا ولبنان والعراق اختبارا لتبيان ما
اذا كان التدخل الايراني في تلك الساحات
مجرد تكتيك في سبيل انجاز تسويه تاريخيه
مع الغرب ام ان المنطقه هي الهدف
الاستراتيجي وما الاتفاق النووي الا رافعه
لتكريس الامر الواقع واذ يحدد ذلك ما سيطر
على المنطقه من تغييرات بعد هذا الاتفاق
انفراجا او تصعيدا فان الانظار تنشد الى
ما ستفعله طهران في اليمن هل تقنع حلفائها
الحوثيين بقبول قرارات الامم المتحده
واعاده الاوضاع الى ما كانت عليها قبل
سيطرتهم على العاصمه صنعاء مما سيوقف
الحرب وينهي الازمه ام تمضي قدما في
موقفها الحالي يفوق ذلك اهميه او يعادله
ربما مستقبل دورها في سوريا هل تنس الى
مطالب السوريين وتتخلى عن دعم الاسد
ونظامه عسكريا وماليا وسياسيا بعدما لم
يؤدي دعمها الا الى اطاله امد الصراع
وراقه مزيد من الدماء سيكون متاحا ربما
معرفه صدقيه التقارير التي تحدثت مرارا عن
ان مصير النظام السوري كان حاضرا دوما في
كواليس التقارب الايراني الامريكي ما
سيحصل في دمشق سينعكس ضروره على لبنان
هناك حيث يتهم حزب الله بقضم الدوله
والتحكم فيها بدليل توريطها عسكريا في
سوريا وعرقله انتخاب رئيس للبلاد حتى الان
ولا يختلف الوضع في العراق كثيرا حيث
اعتبرت ايران لاعبا رئيسيا هناك منذ الغزو
الامريكي ولا يعرف الان بعد اتفاقها
النووي هذا اتوقف دعمها لهذا الطرف على
حساب ذاك الطرف بما يخفف الاحتقان ويجبر
السلطه الحاكمه بعد رفع الرعايه عنها على
تنفيذ خريطه المصالحه الوطنيه ام تستمر
ربما في اعتبار العراق وغيره مجرد ساحات
نفوذ وجبهات متقدمه لمواجهه يفترض من الان
فصاعدا ان تنتفي حتى كشعارات وهو الشكل
الذي يقول كثيرون انها كانت عليه خلال كل
السنين الماضيه اللهم الا مواجهه الارهاب
الذي سيدشن شراكه غير مسبوقه مع واشنطن
والغرب كما تردد عده اوساط جانب من خريطه
المنطقه وتوازنات اذا سيكون مرهونا الان
بالاتفاق الغربي الايراني ووحدها الافعال
ستكون مؤشرا على مدى جديه ايران في لعب
ادوار بناءه ومسؤوله مع جوارها الاقليمي
وضمن المجتمع الدولي بدل التمترس خلف
اجنده خاصه تسوقها تحت عناوين شتى اخفقت
بنظر البعض في التغطيه على حقيقتها
المذهبيه والطائفيه والفارسيه
حتى موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيفين من
جد الكاتب الصحفي جمال خاشقجي ومن طهران
مستشار مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ما شاء الله شمس الواعظين
نرحب بضيفي الكريمين ولعلنا نبدا من جده
معك السيد جمال خاشقجي الكل ادلى بدلوه
بخصوص هذا الاتفاق الا العرب وهم معنيون
بشكل مباشر بالاتفاق وبتبع الاتفاق كيف
تفسر غياب رد فعل عربي الى حد
الان سمه تصريحات قليله هنالك تصريح
اماراتي رحب بالاتفاق ولكن هنالك ايضا
تصريحين
سعوديين عرب عن استيائه من الاتفاق
واحدهما وصف الاتفاق بانه خطا كبير من
الولايات المتحده وانا اتفق معه في هذا
نحن كعرب يهمنا
مصلحتنا الايرانيون نجحوا في فينا ومذ واح
21 شهر في منع مناقشه اي قضايا الا قضيه
ال السلاح النووي والمشروع النووي
الايراني فلم يسمحوا لا ب بمناقشه حقوق
الانسان او الديمقراطيه في ايران او
التدخلات والتوسعات الايرانيه في المنطقه
التي ادت الى ما ادى الى الفوضه التي
نعيشها جميعا واختصر الاتفاق على الموضوع
النووي ا في ظل ظروف عاديه كنا سنرحب بهذا
الاتفاق لانه اذا يبعد ايران عن التسلح
النووي في هذا خبر جيد لنا وخبر جيد
لايران ويؤدي الى تعاون اقتصادي بيننا
وبينها ولكن لا يمكن ان نرحب بهذا الاتفاق
في ظل السياسه العدوانيه الايرانيه مع
ا العالم الان يعيد الاحترام لهذه الدوله
الخارجه على اي النظام الدولي
وانا استغرب من العالم ان لا يثير
المخالفات الدوليه التي تمارسها ايران مثل
ارسال البراميل المتفجره الى سوريا وفي
ذلك مخالفه دوليه مثل ارسال ميليشيات
تتدخل في الشان السوري وتقتل الشعب السوري
وفي ذلك مخالفه
دوليه ف فهذا يدعو للقلق يدعو للقلق دعنا
نتوقف عند هذه الكلمه سيد جمال ساعود طبعا
اليك اتحول السيد ما شاء الله شمس
الواعدين على الاقل بعد ما سمعناه من سيد
جمال خاشقجي لا ترحيب اذا بهذا الاتفاق في
ظل سياسه ايران العدوانيه هو شعور تشترك
فيه العديد من الدول العربيه في المنطقه
باعتقادك ايران بعد هذا الاتفاق كيف سيكون
سلوكها تجاه المنطقه بمختلف ملفاتها هي
التي كان يعاب عليها التمترس خلف اجنده
تحكمها الايديولوجيه تحكمها اشياء
كثيره
مساء الخير اولا اعتقد ان ايران
وبعد الانتهاء من عمليه الاتفاق النووي مع
دول 5 زئ واح ستحرك اليتها الدبلوماسيه
نحو الاقليم
والقضايا
الاقليميه كما اشرت دائما ليس فقط لتبديد
المخاوف او
الهواجس الم موجوده في الدول
الشقيقه في في الشرق الاوسط وخاصه الدول
العربيه الخليجيه
بل وانها ستحاول ايضا لايجاد الشراكه
الاقليميه
لمحاربه الارهاب وهو
العنوان الكبير
لتحدي الاكبر في الشرق الاوسط في هذه
المرحله الارهاب الذي يضرب بلا هواده جميع
الدول او او العمق الاستراتيجي للدول في
في العربيه السعوديه في الكويت في تونس في
مصر وفي كل مكان اعتقد ان ايران وبعد
انتهائها من هذه المرحله الحساسه لانها
كانت دائما عندما تشارك في القضايا
الاقليميه كان العائق النووي هو الذي يسد
مشاركه ايران في العديد من هذا العائق سيد
ما شاء الله اتحول الى السيد جمال خاشقجي
مره اخرى اشار سيد ما شاء الله الى نقطه
مهمه وهي محاربه الارهاب في المنطقه ما
يشير اليه اشارت اليه الولايات المتحده
صراحه اوباما قال بان هذا الاتفاق سيمثل
مرحله جديده في التعاون الغربي الايراني
في محاربه الارهاب وهي كما يعلم الجميع
اولويه غربيه وكما يبدو اولويه ايرانيه
باتت ايضا يعني ترتيب الاولويات بهذه
طريقه الا يتضارب مع المصالح العربيه هي
التي ترى بان هذا الارهاب ليس نتاج سوى
لممارسات خاطئه اصلا في
المنطقه تماما كما ذكرتي وان كنت اتمنى ان
يكون حديث السيد شمس ال الواعظين في
الاتجاه الصحيح وان ايران سوف تغتنم هذه
الانفراج للبدء بسياسه جديده بسياسه جديده
في المنطقه اي نعم من الممكن ان تتعاون
السعوديه وايران اي ان ان صدقنا جميعا
باحلال السلام في المنطقه ولو نبدا مثلا
باستخدام الديمقراطيه في سوريا واليمن
فندم انتخابات حره في البلدين ولا احسب ان
الايرانيين سو سوف يفعلون ذلك لانهم كل
سياستهم السابقه سياستهم طائفيه وتنصب نحو
اقليات تحرضها على الغالبي في ال
اي في البلاد العربيه وهذا ادى الى الصراع
الذي نعيشه لكن بالتاكيد الفرصه متاحه ل
لكني اشك ان هذا سوف يحصل اها سيد ما شاء
الله يعني ما يشير اليه سيد جمال بخصوص
التدخل الايراني في المنطقه سوريا والعراق
واليمن وغيرها من المناطق هل باعتقادك هذا
التدخل في مختلف ملفات المنطقه كان مجرد
تكتيك للخروج بهذا الاتفاق واح احداث
انجاز في هذا الاتفاق ام ان المنطقه في
الواقع هي الهدف الاستراتيجي وما هذا
الاتفاق سوى فرصه ربما رافعه لتحقيق هذا
الهدف هذا السيده فيروز ه هذه المساله
بالذات هو سؤال جيد و وجيه اعتقد ان فيما
يتعلق وهنا اتحدث الى زميلي السيد جمال من
الرياض اعتقد هناك مقوله في الساحتين
السوريه واليمنيه هناك مبدا يقول عندما
تتقدم القضايا الامنيه وخاصه الملحه منها
مثل
الارهاب س تتغير اللعبه وتتغير موازين
القوى
وتتغير الاولويات في سلم
الاولويات هناك مثلا في بريطانيا عندما
ضرب الهراب قطار مترو لندن
جاء رئيس وز وزراءها ليقول ان الامن يتقدم
كل شيء حتى الديمقراطيه لذلك اعتقد عندما
الارهاب يضرب في هذه الساحتين وفي ساحات
عده من الدول العربيه يكون تكون القضيه
الامنيه في في سلم الاولويات لكل الدول
وهنا اشير الى خاصه الى الدول او القوى
الاقليميه الكبيره منها العربيه السعوديه
وايران ل تتعاون
في في مجالات
مثمره
لمحاربه الارهاب والقضيه الامنيه التي
تتصدر المشهد الامني في في ساحات عده في
الوطن العربي ولكن لماذا لا يتم سي سيد ما
شاء الله لماذا لا يتم احترام النظره
العربيه على ان هذا الارهاب هو في نهايه
الامر نتيجه وليس يعني كان موجودا من قبل
هو نتيجه لسياسات خاطئه انتهجت في منطقه
من مختلف الفاعلين
فيها هذا صحيح
ولكن الكل وكل وكل دوله لها لها مواقفها
ولها مبادئها ولها تفسيراتها وقراءتها
قراءه ايران وتفسير ايران لما يحدث في
سوريا تختلف جدا وبصوره ماهيه عنما تفسر
السعوديه او او القراءه السعوديه لقضايا
لقضايا الشرق اوسطيه بالتاكيد هنالك
اختلاف للقراءه وا اختلاف لوجهات النظر
ينطلق منها كل طرف سيد جمال قبل ان نذهب
الى فاصل يعني لطالما العرب يضعون اللوم
على ايران هناك من يرى بان ايران في نهايه
الامر كانت شاطره مثل ما يقولون يعني
امتلكت اوراق ضغط وعرفت كيف تفاوض بها
وبالتالي اخذت ما تريده لماذا يغيب العرب
ولا يوجه اللوم لهم اسرائيل قالت بانها
بالفعل كان كانت حاضره وقدمت لها نسخه من
هذا الاتفاق لتبدي الراي وليس فقط الاطلاع
عليه لماذا لا يعامل ال العرب بنفس
الطريقه اين
الخلل طبعا في خلل في الصفا العربي لا شك
في ذلك والا لما كانت ايران توسعت في
عالمنا مثل خلال العقد
الماضي ولكن قوه ايران او شطاره ايران
التي اشرت اليها لا يعني ان انها اخلاقيا
في في المكان الص صحيح ايران تناصر
دكتاتور في سوريا وديكتاتور اخر في اليمن
لا اعتقد ان الامام الخميني الذي اراد ان
يقيم دوله العداله كما وعد
بها يتفق مع ان يرى بلاده او جمهوريته
الاسلاميه في هذا هذا الوضع اريد ان اعرج
بس بسرعه على المقوله التي اشار اليها
السيد شمس الواعظين والتي نسبها الى
كاميرون بان
عندما عندما يحصل ص الارهاب لا مجال
للديمقراطيه هذه مقوله مكذوبه وغير صحيحه
ولا اسمعها الا من مثقف ايراني او مثقف
مصري هم اكثر من يستخدمونها وهي غير صحيحه
ال تفسيرنا للارهاب هو التفسير الصحيح وهو
ان الارهاب الذي حصل ضرب المنطقه هو نتيجه
دفع سياسه طائفيه في العراق دفع وحمايه
مستبد في سوريا و وتقسيم اليمن على طائفيا
مره اخرى و ودعما مستبد هذا يؤدي الى ضيق
الشعوب و ويعطي فرصه لجماعه كداعش اذا
الايرانيون يريدون المشاركه معنا يجب ان
نقيم حكومات عادله راشده في هذه البلدان
بحيث ترضي الشعوب وبالتالي نحارب الارهاب
لكن لا لا توجد اي اشاره وانا منزعج جدا
من بدايه حديث الروس ومعهم الامريكان حول
ان هذا الاتفاق سوف يؤدي الى محاربه
الارهاب نحن العرب بحاجه اذا الى حمله
لتقديم التفسير الصحيح للارهاب الارهاب
ليس لم يهبط علينا هكذا انما هو
منتوج نتيجه تردي الاوضاع في المنطقه وقد
شاركت ايران في تردي الاوضاع لنا دور
تاريخي نحن العرب الدكتاتوريات العسكر
ولكن الايرانيين لهم دور ايضا في ذلك ومن
المؤلم انه الامريكان بداوا يوافقوا
الايرانيين في ذلك هذا طبعا حديثنا سيد
جمال وسيد ما شاء الله لكن الان س نب الى
فاصل قصير سنناقش بعد التاثيرات المحتمله
لهذا الاتفاق على مواقف ايران في المنطقه
ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الانعكاسات المحتمله لاتفاق ايران
النووي على مواقفها من ملفات الصراع في
المنطقه نرحب مره اخرى بضيفي الكريمين
نتحول الى طهران هذه المره والسيد ما شاء
الله شمس الواعدين سيد جمال ذكر
بان ايران تناصر ديكتاتوريات المنطقه في
وفي اكثر من بلد عربي وان سياساتها كما
يرى كثيرون ليست بريئه تماما وايديها ليست
نظيفه تماما في المنطقه هل بعد هذا
الاتفاق ايران ستعدل من سلوكها غير المرضي
عنه غير المرغوب فيه في المنطقه في اي
اتجاه سيكون سلوكها بخصوص مختلف ملفات
المنطقه
يا يا اخي جمال انا اعتقد عندما نتحدث
بهذه الطريقه وبهذا الاسلوب انا اتمكن ان
اطرح ايضا ان العربيه السعوديه تساند
الدكتاتوريات والانقلابات العسكريه في مصر
وفي بعض البلدان العربيه ليس الكلام في في
في في هذا المجال وعندما نقلت عن عن رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني هو كان توني بنير وليس
كاميرون الذي جاء ليقدم المقوله الامنيه
وخير مثال على ذلك في هذه المرحله الا
تحضى تونس بالنظام الديمقراطي الوليد
والفتي لماذا اعلنت حاله الطوارئ عندما
ضرب الارهاب مدينه السوس السياحيه
وضرب السياحي
لذلك لذلك اعتقد السيده فيروز اعتقد ان
سلوكيات ايران
قضيه القضايا العربيه اعتقد ان لا لا يوجد
هناك موقف عربي موحد من القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه هناك تفسيرات هناك مواقف
هناك استراتيجات تعار بعضها البعض
وهناك لا سؤالي هنا الى الى اي ركن تركن
ايران في الشرق الاوسط مع الدول الار
العربيه التي تعاني من ضياع في الافق
وتعاني من ضياع
الاستراتيجيات الاقليميه والدوليه والرؤى
الاستراتيجيه فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا الاقليميه عندما نتحدث عن الدول
العربيه ونتحدث عن هل هناك نظام اقليمي
عربي موحد لكي نتمكن ان ان نتعامل مع خطاب
موحد ولذلك تعامل او تحاسب ايران على انها
ابتعدت او اقتربت من خطاب عربي موحد ام لا
لا يوجد هذا الخطاب يا سيده فيروز ويا يا
اخي جمال هناك شتى المواقف لذلك ايران
عندما تتعامل مع الدول العربيه تتعامل مع
استراتيجيات متعارضه وم متاز انت تشير الى
نقطه مهمه ساحوه للسيد جمال اذا العرب شتى
وليسوا على موقف واحد اما ان لهم الان ان
يوحدوا كلمتهم ويتعاملوا مع ايران كقوه
فاعله وامر واقع بمنطق المصالح وليس باي
منطق
اخر كلام صحيح المشروع العربي الوحيد
المتوفر اليوم لمواجهه حاله الانهيار في
العالم العربي والتمدد الايراني هو
المشروع السعودي الذي اختصره في عاصفه
الحزم او مبدا سلمان هذا المشروع الذي
انطلق من اليمن سوف يستمر باذن
الله وعدد من الدول العربيه خاص الخليجيه
منها متحالفه مع المملكه في ذلك ودول
اسلاميه وعربيه اخرى بشكل متباين بعضها
متحالف معنا تماما وبعضها متحالف معنا في
بعض التفاصيل فثم مشروع مهم وله رؤيه
استراتيجيه هو المشروع السعودي ولا يوجد
مشروع غيره حتى الان الذي اتمناه من بلدي
ان لا تعطي
ايران بعد توقيع الاتفاقيه هذه لا ايران
ولا السيد
اوباما
بطاقه بيضاء او توقيع على بياض وتدعم هذا
الاتفاق وانما يجب علينا ان نضغط قدر ما
نستطيع من والتصدي للشغب الايراني كما قال
عادل الجبير في الاردن يعني نفس
الاستراتيجيه قبل الاتفاق وبعدها
معاني ول ولكن ايضا ان امام اوباما 60 يوم
لاقرار هذا الاتفاق يجب ان لا تكون سهله
المهمه يجب ان نضغط على الامريكان وعلى
المجتمع الدولي لتعطيل هذا الاتفاق ما لم
يتحسن الاداء الايراني والخلق الايراني في
المنطقه حينها نستطيع ان نتعاون معهم اما
في ظل العدوانيه الايرانيه يجب علينا ان
لا نعطي الايرانيين ممتا في ظل هذه
العدوانيه الايرانيه لا يمكن اعطاء
الايرانيين ما يريدونه اذا ايران بعد هذا
الاتفاق نظرتها للمنطقه انفراج ام تصعيد
في اي اتجاه ما اولويات الحكومه الايرانيه
سيد ما شاء
الله اعتقد ان الاولويه هي هي
المشاركه مع الدول العربيه ودول الشرق
الاوسط لمحاربه الارهاب
اي العنوان الاكبر والاخطر في هذه في هذه
المرحله لذلك يعني عندما عندما تضرب
العربيه السعوديه هذا يعني ان الامن يعني
اي ارهاب سيد جمال تحدث بانه يجب تعريف
مفهوم الارهاب اولا حتى
يحارب هذا صحيح لكن عندما عندما راينا
فيما فيما حدث في الكويت وفيما حدث في شرق
السعوديه وفيما وما حدث في تونس
كلنا نقبل مفهوم الارهاب ان هذا الارهاب
التكفيري الذي يضرب كل الدول العربيه
وعمقها الاستراتيجي والاقتصادي هناك ضروره
تحتم على كل الدول وخاصه القوى الاقليميه
الكبيره وتحديدا العربيه السعوديه وايران
لتعاون لتعاون مع مع بعضها البعض لمحاربه
هذا العنوان او هذا الخطر الكبير الدرس
المستفاد سيد جمال خاشقجي من كل هذا يعني
طريقه تعاطي العرب مع الغرب يعني ايران هل
نجحت بربما منطقها المشاغب المشاكس مع
الغرب في اخذ ما ارادت ما الذي اجدى او ما
الذي اعطى العرب ما جدوى ذلك التعاطي
والتحالف الاستراتيجي مع الغرب في نهايه
الامر وهم حتى لم يسالوا ولم يستشار ولم
ترسل اليهم نسخه من هذا الاتفاق كما فعلوا
مع
اسرائيل الدرس المستفاد هو ان الغرب لا
يحترم الا الاقوياء
ا يجب ان ناخذ زمام المبادره مثل ما يفعل
الايرانيون مثل ما يفعل الاسرائيليون يجب
ان ناخذهم المبادره ونتخذ مواقف مستقله
تخدم مصالحنا اولا اعتقد ان عاصمه الحزم
سوف تتحول الى تلك السياسه
نعم ممكن عربيا اذا عزمنا وحزبنا
مثلما جميعا راينا ذلك الدعم الهائل الذي
حضت به المملكه العربيه السعوديه عندما
تحركت بقوه في اليمن فبالتالي يجب ان
نستمر بهذه السياسه وان نضبطها ونحسن
ادائنا ايضا لكي نستطيع ان ننافس هذين
الخصمين في المنطقه اسرائيل وايران اشكرك
جزيل الشكر السيد جمال خاشقجي الكاتب
الصحفي كنت معنا من جده كما اشكر جزيل
الشكر السيد ما شاء الله شمس الواعظين
مستشار م مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه كان معنا من طهران ختام هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه